bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour une nouvelle édition de
24h Sénat et pour commencer voyez cette
image du vote cette nuit de la loi de
programmation militaire un texte qui
fixe le cadre budgétaire de la défense
pour les 6 ans à venir ce projet de loi
a été adopté par 163 voix contre 140 et
en pleine affaire sur l'espionnage
américain le Sénat a intégré dans ce
texte une disposition qui renforce le
cadre légal de l'interception des
communications demain les sénateurs
examineront en commission la réforme des
retraites le texte sera examiné en
séance publique lundi 28 octobre en
attendant les sénateurs centristes ont
présenté leur contre-projet ce matin à
la presse il propose un système je cite
plus équitable et plus lisible écoutez
Jean-Marie vanon lurenberg c'est ur
centriste du pcalis et la réponse de la
sénatrice socialiste Christiane de Mones
elle est membre du corps le Conseil
d'orientation des
retraites nous voulons une réforme juste
équitable du système des retraites
c'est-à-dire une réforme systémique
alors qu'est-ce que ça veut dire réforme
systémique bah c'est une retraite par
point égale pour tous
c'estàdire que la cotisation donne mieu
à des points et que ça se transforme et
après par une pension il faut être
clair les Français ne sont pas prêts à
remettre en cause leur système de
retraite par répartition de toute façon
un changement de système de système ne
réglait pas le problème des déficits de
la branche
retraite du côté du groupe écologiste
les sénateurs hésitent entre
l'abstention et le vote contre la
réforme des retraites pour le sénateur
Europe Écologie Les ver de Paris Jean
Desessard le rallengement du temps de
travail est une hérésie et PU puis
Jean-Vincent Placé le président du
groupe écologiste au Sénat souhaite que
le mouvement lycéen en faveur de la
collégienne Rome léonarda expulsé au
Kosovo reprennent il l'a dit ce matin
sur RTL au Sénat début de l'examen cet
après-midi du projet de loi logement de
Cécile Dufflot pour comprendre les
enjeux de ce texte déjà voté à
l'Assemblée nationale on va retrouver en
direct de l'hémicycle Tam tranui alors
Tam bonjour bonjourine comment se
passent les débats et bien écoutez la
discussion générale a débuté il y a
environ 2h30 elle a débuté comme le veut
la tradition par l'allocution de Cécile
Duflot la ministre du Logement qui a
commencé par défendre deux mesures
emblématiques de ce projet de loi
d'abord la garantie universelle des
loyers qui doit venir remplacer la
caution caution si difficile à réunir
pour certains Français et puis
l'encadrement des loyers en zone tendu
c'est-à-dire dans ces zones où l'offre
est bien inférieure à la demande et où
du coup le montant des loyers peut
s'envoler ce sont de mesures
emblématiques je l'ai dit et qui
focalisent le cour rou de la droite mais
pour autant ce n'est pas sur ces mesures
que la ministre s'est fait le plus
chahutter elle s'est fait le plus
chahuté sur une mesure à priori beaucoup
plus technique sur l'instauration des
plans locaux d'urbanisme intercommunaux
les PLU intercommunaux je rappelle que
ces plu aujourd'hui se décide en mairie
et le fait comme ça de transférer cette
compétence au niveau C supérieur au
niveau intercommunal fait grincer
beaucoup de dents chez les élus locaux
les dents notamment de nombreux élus
ruraux dont les sénateurs se sont fait
les porte-voie de manière assez
bruillante cet après-midi merci beaucoup
Tam pour vos explications on va donc
tout de suite écouter le début de la
discussion générale de ce texte avec
l'intervention de la ministre du
Logement Cécile Duflot et on se retrouve
tout à
l'heure monsieur le
Président Mesdames les les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs au moment où je
monte à cette tribune devant vous je
mesure la gravité du sujet qui nous
occupe et l'importance du travail commun
que nous devons poursuivre pour faire
émerger le meilleur texte de loi
possible qui aujourd'hui peut nier
l'état de tension qui est celui de notre
pays les difficultés nous blessent et
les peurs nous assaille la tentation du
repli sur soi énerve chaque pan de notre
vie sociale si bien ceux qui pensent
qu'il y aurait d'un côté une crise
identitaire et de l'autre une crise
sociale je suis obligé de répondre que
le mal qui vient naît de la conjonction
de ces deux périls et qu'il nous faut
répondre aux deux aspects de la crise
qui frappe notre pays si nous voulons et
je pense que c'est ici partagé continuer
à défendre ensemble les mêmes valeurs
républicaine ces valeurs sont attaquées
non pas seulement par la montée des
populismes mais aussi par la dissolution
de l'esprit de solidarité c'est donc en
ayant en tête que notre mission est bien
la construction d'une république qui
fait place à chacun que j'aborde notre
débat faire France ensemble voilà
l'objectif la cohésion sociale est bel
et bien l'horizon de nos politique
publique or chacun sait que les
questions relatives à l'urbanisme et
surtout au logement sont centrales dans
la construction de notre cohésion
sociale forte de cette conviction j'ai
l'honneur de défendre la loi allure
devant vous il vous appartient de tout
faire pour donner à ce texte
l'efficacité la plus grande et je suis
persuadé que vous vous y emploierez j'ai
pu mesurer l'intérêt qui est celui de
cette chambre pour l'objet qui nous
occupe je vous remercie d'ors et déjà du
souci que vous avez manifesté pour la
discussion qui s'ouvre ces ces
remerciements je ne les formule pas
uniquement mon nom propre mais au nom
d'une certaine idée de la République et
de la défense de l'intérêt général je le
répète et à dessin dans les les mêmes
termes que ceux que j'ai utilisé devant
l'Assemblée nationale ce qui est en jeu
en discussion en gestation ici c'est la
situation de millions de femmes d'hommes
et d'enfants qui veulent pouvoir se
loger et être logés dignement 2 millions
de femmes et d'hommes qui veulent mettre
leur famille à l'abri des difficultés de
l'existence je veux le dire ici
paisiblement mais avec solenité nous
avons un devoir de réussite aussi je
tiens à ce que chaque sénateur et chaque
sénatrice mesure l'impérieuse nécessité
de se départir peut-être de réflexes
partisans traditionnel dans ce qu'ils
ont de confortable mais aussi parfois de
sclérosant nous ne sommes pas là pour
mesurer nos capacités d'influence
respective ou même nous écharper dans de
vine querell mais B et bien pour
construire l'outil législatif adapté à
la situation d'urgence que traverse
notre pays je le dis d'autant plus que
chaque républicain sait les tensions qui
pèsent sur le champ démocratique
la montée des extrémismes phénomène
puissant sur tout le continent européen
trouve dans notre pays une traduction
particulière qui ne peut être combattu
que si chacun à la place qui est la
sienne s'attache à redonner à l'action
publique ses lettres de noblesse
j'espère donc que le débat qui va nous
animer sera de
qualité quel est l'enjeu la réalité
c'est que notre pays est confronté à une
fracture résidentielle d'une telle
ampleur qu'elle constitue une bombe à
retardement qu'il nous faut absolument
désamorcé la loi lureentend le faire en
rétablissement en rétablissant une
égalité d'accès au logement pour se
faire il fallait tourner le dos à une
vision trop longtemps en cours selon
laquelle le marché pouvait seul parvenir
à répondre aux besoins collectifs en
matière de logement nous avons souhaité
ouvrir une voie nouvelle adaptée à la
violence de la crise vécue par nos
concitoyens
elle est basé sur le volontarisme et sur
la prise en compte de la complexité
volontarisme parce que que l'État doit
jouer un rôle de régulateur des excès du
marché pour garantir à chacun la
possibilité de se loger complexité parce
qu'il est impératif que les enjeux
économiques sociaux écologiques et au
final civiques soient embrassés d'un
même mouvement pour qu'une politique
publique du logement soit efficiente
c'est l'esprit et la lettre du texte qui
est ici en
discussion le moteur du projet de loi
que j'ai l'honneur de vous présenter
aujourd'hui se résume en un objectif
favoriser l'accès au L pour tous de ce
tous nul ne doit être exclu et surtout
pas les plus précaires frappés de plein
fouet par la crise du logement je
souhaite si vous me le permettez vous
citez des mots anciens de l'abbé Pierre
quand la loi est ainsi faite que pour
les travailleurs avec leur salaire légal
il est impossible d'avoir un logi pour
abriter humainement un foyer un berceau
ce n'est pas d'entreprendre une
construction sans permis c'est la loi
qui est qui est illégale la logique qui
a largement pré évalu ces dernières
années tendait à croire qu'il suffisait
pour régler la crise de laisser le
marché agir funeste illusion que de
croire que le laisser faire pouvait
offrir des garanties d'accès au logement
d'équité et de cohésion sociale notre
projet de loi tire les leçons de
l'expérience et propose une autre voie
celle de la détermination et de l'action
régulatrice de la puissance publique ce
faisant notre texte marque une rupture
salutaire et rétablit le logement à sa
juste place c'est-à-dire celle d'un bien
de première nécessité pour se faire le
texte ici défendu concrétise d'abord un
engagement du Président de la République
à travers l'encadrement des loyers le
bon sens qui n'est le monopole d'aucune
formation politique commande de bien
saisir l'urgente nécessité d'une telle
démarche cette mesure repose avant tout
sur un constat unanime les loyers ont
augmenté dans certaines zones deux fois
plus vite que l'indice des prix
provoquant ainsi un véritable décrochage
avec le niveau de revenu les locataires
du parc locatif privé supporte les taux
d'efforts les plus élevés pour illustrer
ce phénomène il faut noter qu'en 2010 il
dépensait en moyenne plus de 26 % de
leur revenus pour se loger et pour
certains jusqu'à 40 voire même 50 %.
cette situation n'est pas soutenable
elle n'est pas non plus acceptable à
travers le dispositif proposé nous avons
souhaité avec pragmatisme et réalisme
limiter les excès sans pour autant
entrer dans une logique de prise
administrée l'examen du texte à
l'Assemblée nationale et à la commission
des affaires économiques du Sénat ont
renforcé notre mécanisme le rendant à la
fois plus lisible et plus efficace
notamment en fixant un seuil au loyers
médian minorés pour s'assurer que
l'encadrement des loyers profite au plus
modeste nous avons précisé que la
fixation des loyers médians de référence
s'opérait au niveau des loyers au mètre
carré vivant dans des logements de plus
peties superficie ce sont en effet les
ménages les plus défavorisés qui payent
aujourd'hui des loyers au mètes carré
les plus élevés enfin votre commission
s'est saisi du sujet en affirmant que
les caractéristiques du complément de
loyer seront exceptionnelles les
avancées issues du débat parlementaire
sont donc conséquentes et je pense que
nous devons poursuivre cette dynamique
et ce dialogue c'est ensemble que nous
aboutirons à un dispositif fonctionnel
et pérenne qui puisse et qui pourra
répondre aux attentes légitimes de nos
concitoyens une autre mesure du projet
de loi est particulièrement
représentative du volontarisme qui est
le nôtre je veux ici parler de la gulle
la garantie universelle du logement
porte l'ambition d'ouvrir à terme un
nouvelâge de la recherche de logement
cette ambition n'est pas vaine le
parcours du combattant que décrivent des
centaines de milliers de personnes
désireuses de se loger dignement doit
trouver un terme la Gul permettra
d'apaiser les relations entre
propriétaires et locataires en les
protégeant contre les coups durs de
l'existence dont nul n'est à l'abri
l'effet de la gulle si nous lui donnons
vie sera de pacifier les relations entre
les acteurs entre le locataire qui ne
sera pas laissé seul lorsqu'il est
frappé par un drame de la vie et le
propriétaire qui ne sera plus démuni
face à l'impayé un tiers sera chargé de
prendre en charge à la fois le risque et
la responsabilité ce seront les
professionnels dont l'intervention sera
agréée par un cahier des charges et
régulé il est essentiel d'adopter cette
mesure qui je le pense est une mesure de
concorde et je pèse mes mots de progrès
social la première injustice en matière
de logement n'est-elle pas en effet de
s'en voir refuser l'accès ou d'être
obligé de des preuves exorbitantes de
solvabilité nous devons faire reculer
l'angoisse face au sentiments
d'arbitraire les jeunes les précaires
les familles monoparentales les
personnes âgées et en particulier les
femmes disposant d'une très faible
retraite les personnes dont l'origine la
couleur de peau ou le patronyme les
expos à la discrimination sont autant de
catégories de population qui désirent
sortir de l'angoisse face au logement la
Gul permettra de lutter contre toutes
les discriminations à l'entrée au log
dans le logement en recréant les les
conditions de la confiance avec la gulle
les propriétaires et les locataires
seront accompagnés les propriétaires
seront indemnisés se verront proposer un
plan d'AP purement réaliste pour
garantir leur revenus plus souvent
modeste qu'on ne dit on donnera
l'assistance nécessaire s'il y a lieu
pour faire face un locataire de mauvaise
foi au locataire de bonne foi on offrira
la maintendue dont chacun peut avoir
besoin on proposera l'accompagnement
nécessaire dans la recherche d'un
nouveau logement laagul sera un outil
nouveau au service de la détection et de
la prévention des situations d'urgence
sociale avant que la spirale de la dette
ne devienne infernale c'est pourquoi
lorsque nous avons réfléchi à la mise en
place de la caution solidaire pour les
jeunes promise par le Président de la
République il est vite apparu que la
seule solution et de mutualiser les
risques sur la base la plus large sur
l'ensemble du parc locatif privé que
pour répondre aux préoccupations de la
jeunesse il fallait répondre aux
préoccupations de tous cette solution ne
tombe d'ailleurs pas du ciel elle est le
fruit de plusieurs années de réflexion
parlementair et même de ministres et
d'engagement c'est aussi celle que
recommandait la Alde en 2010 pour faire
cesser les discriminations dans le
secteur du logement si la GRL alors
lancée ne réussissait pas on entend ici
poindre l'argument parfois selon lequel
les locataires se trouveraient
déresponsabilisés par avance absous de
leurs impayés naturellement non c'est
même sans doute le contraire c'est
l'inverse que permet la les locataires
de mauvaise foi qui ne sont pas très
nombreux seront redevables vis-à-vis
d'un système organisé et protecteur des
propriétaires au propriétaire démuni
face à l'impayé se substituera le relais
de professionnel à la fois de
l'accompagnement du locataire et du
recouvrement qui permettra de recouvrer
efficacement en limitant l'extension
infinie de la dette de locataire qu'on
laisse s'enfoncer est-ce que cela veut
dire que le gouvernement veut créer une
nouvelle administration en aucun cas
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion asion de le dire
pour mettre en œuvre cette mission
nouvelle d'indemnisation et de
prévention le gouvernement s'appuera sur
un système public et privé sur ceux qui
savent faire et ne sont donc pas
nécessairement dans cette matière des
agents publics vous l'aurez compris
laagulle est une avancée législative
majeure parce qu'elle défend des
principes de justice et les encre dans
la réalité de la vie quotidienne je
postule qu'une fois adopté et dans
quelques années cette mesure qui suscite
aujourd'hui des débats fera sans doute
partie du patrimoine de droit
républicain précieux c'est à vous comme
à chaque moment où la République fait
progresser certains droits qu'il vous
revient d'accomplir ce pas en avant
favoriser l'accès au logement pour tous
c'est l'objectif de ce projet de loi je
le répète dans cet esprit je tiens à
mettre en exerg devant vous deux enjeux
essentiels auxquels s'attaque le projet
de loi l'orientation de la politique
d'hébergement vers le logement d'une
part et la prévention des expulsions
d'autre part je suis ici parfaitement
lucide ces dispositions n'auront rien ni
de magique ni d'instantané pour autant
elles sont capitales depuis trop
longtemps les secteurs de l'hébergement
et du Logement fonctionnent comme deux
ensembles distincts de monde étranger
qui ne communiquent pas ou pas assez
cette séparation condamne les personnes
les plus en difficulté qui n'ont pour
quotidien que des allés etretour entre
la rue et les centres d'hébergement les
mesures du projet de loi consacrées au
services d'insertion d'accueil et
d'orientation et au plans départementaux
d'action pour le logement et
l'hébergement des personnes défavorisées
ont le mérite de construire les ponts
pour rapprocher ces secteurs
l'hébergement est un moyen lorsqu'il est
nécessaire mais le logement demeure
l'objectif primordial assortie d'un
accompagnement adapté aux personnes qui
ont besoin d'un soutien avant d'être à
même de vivre de manière autonome une
articulation plus fine entre ces mondes
de l'hébergement et du Logement
permettra j'en suis convaincu de
favoriser l'accès et l'insertion durable
dans un logement digne et adapté des
personnes les plus démunies le second
enjeu que je mentionna est celui de la
prévention des expulsions améliorer les
dispositions en la matière signifie
contribuer à enrayer la mécanique de
l'exclusion et agir pour anticiper les
ruptures en période de crise cette
réalité se pose avec d'autant plus
d'acuité le chemin qui mène à
l'expulsion n'est pas si long le
décrochage peut être brutal et pousser
n'importe quelle personne pour une
raison ou une autre fragilisé par la vie
dans la rue ou dans des solutions très
précaires d'hébergement la perte du
logement est souvent synonyme de F
de brisure des liens sociaux et même
familiaux c'est un effondrement une
humiliation une blessure terrible pour
celle ou celui qui l'a subi améliorer la
prévention des expulsions c'est tout
faire pour que les ménages puissent se
maintenir dans leur logement j'étais
très attaché à ce que le projet de loi
contienne des mesures visant à traiter
les impayés le plus en amont possible et
à renforcer le rôle des instances
chargées de coordonner la prévention des
expulsions mais je tiens à souligner
combien le travail parlementaire a
permis de renforcer ce volet le
signalement obligatoire des impayés à la
CAPEX a été élargi les possibilités du
juge d'accorder des délis au ménag en un
pays ont été accrus le maintien des
aides personnelles au logement pour les
allocataires de bonne foi a été inscrit
dans le projet de loi je me réjouis de
savoir que nombre d'entre vous partagent
ma volonté de poursuivre la réflexion
sur ce sujet et que nous aurons ainsi
l'occasion d'en débattre et
d'approfondir le projet de loi dans cet
hémicycle enfin le projet de loi allure
prévoit aussi de développer sur des
bases plus ge la participation des
personnes en situation de pauvreté et de
précarité à l'élaboration et au suivi
des politiques publiques promouvoir des
méthodes de de coconstruction et
d'évaluation participative c'est assumer
la meilleure appréciation du bien fondé
d'une politique qui émane donc de celles
et ceux qui en vivent les effets en
dernier lieu mon intervention n'aurait
pas tout son sens si je n'abordais pas
la question de la construction de
logement la nécessité de développer
l'offre de logement pour lutter contre
la crise du logement nous engage tous et
toutes chacun dans nos
responsabilités la responsabilité du
gouvernement c'est de conduire la
politique de la nation et la politique
de ce gouvernement c'est de faire
confiance à la démocratie d'être
attentif aux femmes et aux hommes de ce
pays plutôt qu'à la seule rentabilité
financière je suis ministre du Logement
et je ne peux me satisfaire de la
manière dont le marché du logement
fonctionne aujourd'hui de son blocage de
ce qu'il produit comme exclusion quand
je dis que le logement est un bien de
première nécessité je veux vous rappeler
à quel point il conditionne tout le
reste la scolarité des enfants l'accès à
l'emploi qu'on ne s'y trompe pas bien
plus que de parcours résidentiel on
parle de trajectoire de vie de vie tout
simplement la responsabilité du
législateur c'est de voter la loi et de
déterminer les règles qui vont permettre
d'organiser la société en matière de
logement forcé de constater que ces
règles ne sont pas satisfaisante j'y
reviendrai en matière de politique
foncière d'urbanisme ou d'aménagement la
loi vient définir les outils qui seront
à la disposition des élus locaux pour
organiser le fonctionnement du
territoire dont ils ont la
responsabilité la responsabilité des
élus locaux de nos villes comme de nos
campagnes c'est de se saisir de ces
outils au service d'un projet pour leur
territoire dans le respect de la loi
pour résoudre la crise du logement il
faut que chacun soit tourné vers cet
objectif et contribue à lever les
difficultés les blocages m à disposition
les moyens l'État doit en prendre sa
part et il l'a fait en mobilisant le
foncier public susceptible d'accueillir
des projets de logement à travers les
premières ordonnances publiées depuis
juillet le gouvernement crée les
conditions les plus favorables à une
relance de la construction celles qui
permettront de lever les freins et les
contraintes techniques qui font qu'un
projet ne se fait pas non pas parce
qu'il est mauvais mais parce qu'il est
singulier ponctuel et doit être fait sur
mesure au-delà de ces mesures d'urgence
ce projet de loi vous propose d'adopter
des dispositions structurelles
l'orientation de ce gouvernement que je
suis fière de porter consiste à
affronter les questions qui se pose avec
détermination avec courage et avec
fermeté rendre possible ce qui n'est
aujourd'hui que souhaitable c'est
affronter la question de la préservation
des terres agricoles et des terres
naturelles on ne peut plus faire ou
laisser faire le contraire de ce de que
ce que chacun reconnaît comme une fuite
en avant on ne peut plus continuer à
Sommer des terres naturelles et
agricoles de manière inconséquente au
rythme où nous le faisons rendant plus
difficile encore chaque jour l'
l'installation de jeunes agriculteurs
par exemple pour lutter efficacement
contre l'étalement urbain il faut non
seulement une politique de maîtrise et
d'anticipation foncière intelligente
mais il faut aussi aux élus les moyens
de cette politique les communes et les
intercommunalités doivent disposer de
l'ingénierie foncière la plus efficace
pour répondre aux besoins spécifiques de
chaque territoire ce qui veut dire
disposer des moyens qui leur permettront
au mieux de concrétiser leur stratégie
de développement et mettre en œuvre des
projets de réhabilitation de leurs
centres anciens leur projets
d'aménagement résolument tourné vers
l'avenir c'est la raison pour laquelle
je souhaite que les opérateurs fonciers
se développe qu'il s'agisse
d'établissement publics fonciers de
l'État ou locaux les uns comme les
autres sont au service des territoires
la différence entre les deux c'est que
l'État au nom de l'égalité des
territoires et de l'intérêt général a la
capacité d'Inter venir quand la volonté
ou les moyens sont défaillants l'État
intervient pour garantir le respect des
orientations stratégiques qu'il fixe et
qui vise par exemple à ce que
l'opérateur foncier dont il assure la
tutelle permette aux collectivités qui
sont en situation de carence d'optimiser
la ressource foncière pour respecter la
loi SRU en revanche là où des
établissements fonciers publics locaux
existent et remplissent déjà leur
mission de de façon satisfaisante le
projet de loi vient conforter leur
mission et étayer leurs outils en
portant le projet de loi allure c'est un
droit de l'urbanisme rénové que je vous
présente aujourd'hui un régime de
planification réformée et résolument
tourné vers la transition écologique des
territoires je veux remettre au cœur de
l'objectif la celle de celui de la
construction de logement la question de
l'aménagement du territoire trop
longtemps on a refusé de voir que
l'urbanisme est un enjeu politique qui
se trouve au confluent de la question de
la géographie sociale de la question
environ
des questions économiques et de la
question sociale l'urbanisme c'est
l'espace vécu ressenti et parfois subi
ces dernières années par choix ou par
renoncement les ménages se sont
essentiellement tournés vers la
périphérie des villes aujourd'hui ce
sont plus de 80 % de la population et
des emplois qui trouvent place dans
l'espace périurbain et nous le savons
malheureusement bien la périurbanisation
est synonyme de consommation excessive
de nos espaces naturels pourtant
l'urbanisation galopante et la
concentration de nos cités ne sont pas
une fatalité un autre modèle urbain est
indispensable mais il ne pourra émerger
sans un changement d'approche tirons les
leçons de l'intelligence écologique
accumulée depuis de longues années rien
de ce qui détruit indument des espaces
naturels ne saurait être considéré comme
durablement profitaable à l'intérêt
général nos terres naturelles
forestières et agricoles doivent être
préservé elles sont devenues un bien
précieux qui nécessite d'être protégé un
bien commun dont la préservation
constitue un devoir républicain à part
entière il est temps de mettre un terme
à l'artificialisation des sols là encore
je fais confiance aux élus pour qu'il
définissent les conditions de
constructibilité sur leur territoire à
travers les des documents de
planification en revanche il nous faut
mettre un terme à la logique des
dérogations partielles au coup par coup
qui sont le contraire d'une politique
durable en la matière la
constructibilité limitée en l'absence de
documents d'urbanisme est avant tout une
invitation aux élus à se doter de
document d'urbanisme et à faire le choix
d'exercer pleinement leurs compétences
en se dotant d'un document de
planification nous devons être ambitieux
en engageant une mutation de notre
habitat au sens large autrement dit de
nos quartiers de nos villes de nos
territoires le projet de loi pour
l'accès au logement et un urbanisme
rénové donne à voir une façon nouvelle
de penser de fabriquer et au final
d'habiter la ville c'est une vision à
long terme bien sûr le tournant
écologique ne se réalisera pas en un
jour mais je prends ma part de cette
agionento dans le champ ministériel dont
j'ai la charge la ville durable devra et
verra le jour elle dépendra largement de
nos stratégies de développement mis en
œuvre à travers les politiques
d'aménagement et d'urbanisme et de notre
capacité à construire plus tout en
construisant mieux c'est-à-dire là où
sont les besoins les documents de
planification seront demain plus que
jamais essentiels à cette démarche de
transition écologique des territoires à
laquelle nous travaillons c'est pourquoi
ils doivent gagner en sécurité juridique
en en lisibilité et remplir les
objectifs qui leur sont assignés à
chaque échelle du territoire c'est dans
ce sens que sera renforcé le schéma de
cohérence territorial il assurera demain
l'intégration de l'ensemble des
politiques d'aménagement à l'échelle du
bassin de vie le plan local d'urbanisme
traduira les objectifs du Scott au
niveau opérationnel si le SCOT définit
des espaces naturels à préserver le PLU
organise leur protection jusqu'à
l'échelle la plus fine celle des
parcelles en classant les espaces boisés
en adaptant le zonage et son dispositif
réglementaire en formulant des
orientations d'aménagement et de
programmation spécifique ou encore en
organisant la maîtrise de l'étalement
urbain par la densification des zones
déjà bâties cette organisation spatiale
de nos territoires sera d'autant plus
pertinente qu'elle aura associée à son
élaboration l'ensemble des communes à
l'échelle
intercommunale vous le savez cette
discussion a eu lieu et ici déjà
plusieurs fois je suis convaincue que
l'aménagement durable passe par
l'élaboration de documents d'urbanisme à
à l'échelle intercommunale je connais et
j'ai entendu les réserves qui se sont
exprimées sur certains bands de cette
assemblée et je souhaiterais ici tâcher
d'y répondre et j'espère vous en
convaincre
l'élaboration l'élaboration à l'échelle
intercommunale par la mutualisation des
moyens et des compétences qu'elle permet
exprime et incarne la solidarité entre
les territoires que nous appelons de nos
vœux l'efficacité d'abord nous le savons
les Français ne travaillent plus là où
ils vivent il s'agit donc de se doter
d'une politique qui au plus près des
territoires met en cohérence les
politiques de l'aménagement du logement
et l'urbanisme choisie et décidé par les
élus l'intercommunalité vise à
coordonner et non pas à se substituer à
l'action des communes la mutualisation
des moyens ensuite à l'heure où l'état
des finances publiques au niveau local
comme nationale exige de nous une plus
grande efficacité cela doit nous
permettre de mettre en commun les
savoir-faire de FA faoriser la rencontre
des ingénieries et des expertises de
choisir l'intelligence commune la
solidarité enfin c'est le meilleur
niveau pour que s'exprime une véritable
solidarité entre les collectivités chose
à laquelle je suis particulièrement
sensible en tant que ministre de
l'Égalité des territoires c'est parce
que nous serons aménager de manière
équitable et équilibrée que nous
pourrons garantir à nos concitoyens un
égal accès au servic publics et une
véritable mixité des espaces que nous
établirons la confiance c'est pour ces
raisons que de nombreux maires ont déjà
fait le choix de ce niveau tous ceux qui
sont passés au PLU intercommunal s'en
félicitent aujourd'hui il me semble
qu'il est temps pour nous de consacrer
dans la loi à ce niveau comme l'échelon
pertinent de la planification alors
puisqu'il faut le dire je vais le dire
avec netteté je ne veux le gouvernement
ne veut déposséder aucun élu de sa
faculté à exercer ses
compétences
j'entends
j'ai entendu les craintes des maires et
de certains élus à commencé par ceux des
territoires ruraux et je le redis la
volonté d'efficacité ne doit pas mettre
en danger le niveau communal qui est
celui de la proximité et de l'expression
de la volonté des citoyens à aucun
moment à aucun moment l'élaboration d'un
plu intercommunale ne les privera de
cette prérogative essentielle que sont
les autorisations d'urbanisme les permis
de construire je veux décentraliser et
faire
confiance aux collectivités et à leurs
élus
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui messieurs les
sénateurs qui m'interpellent plus près
de 40 % de ces communes essentiellement
des communes rurales ne sont ouverte par
aucun document d'urbanisme elle relève
du règlement national d'urbanisme où
c'est l'état ou c'est l'État qui
instruit et délivre les autorisations
d'urbanisme je crois que cette
question je crois que cette question
mérite du respect de
l'attention s'il vous plaît madame la
ministre si vous voulez bien la que ce
sujet mérite de l'attention et de la
précision faute de documents
d'urbanisme les élus souvent en
territoires ruraux se trouvent privés de
fait de toute maîtrise de la politique
d'urbanisme en généralisant les PLU nous
leur donnons les moyens de devenir
demain les maîtres de leur territoire
mon Paris c'est la confiance ma méthode
c'est la conviction et je vous propose
donc une direction volontaire je veux
faire avec vous en l'ayant partagé avec
de nombreux sénateurs le Paris de la
responsabilité des élus locaux qui
auront à cœur de déterminer ce qui est
le mieux par leurs pour leurs
administrés je souhaite que la question
du PLU intercommunal soit posée dans
chaque PCI pour que cet échange ait lieu
et que chacun exprime et mesure les
conséquences concrètes pour l'avenir de
son territoire l'amendement que vous
avez adopté en commission des affaires
économiques sur la proposition du
rapporteur me semble alors relev de la
meilleure méthode demain
l'intercommunalité pourra être la règle
et non plus l'exception mais dès lors
que les maires ne le souhaiteront pas
ils auront à leur main les outils pour
que leur volonté soit respectée je
souhaite
donc je souhaite donc transférer sans
jamais
imposer je veux le dialogue comme
pratique et la volonté des élus comme
méthode j'ai entendu cette crainte
relayée par les sénateurs et j'y étais
plus que sensible je souhaite que la
réponse soit effective et elle est
lisible dans l'amendement que vous avez
adopté en commission des affaires
économiques c'est pour moi la voie pour
une politique d'urbanisme mise au
service de l'intérêt général et appuyé
sur les projets des territoire et de
leurs élus voilà ce que je souhaitais
souligner en ouverture de notre
discussion que je souhaite féconde et
que j'ai déjà compris comme
franche je le dis en remerciant
l'ensemble des sénateurs et des
sénatrices qui se sont fortement
impliqué sur ce texte depuis des mois et
depuis quelques jours je le dis en
remerciant euh les quatre rapporteurs
enfin les trois rapporteurs et la
rapporteur qui ont travaillé sur ce
projet de loi je le dis en remerciant le
président de la commission des affaires
économiques qui a porté un soin tout
particulier à ce que le débat s'installe
autour de la Commission sur ces sujets
qui sont des sujets à la fois très
technique et qui je le dis peuvent
rencontrer une large adhésion sur un
certain nombre de leurs aspects
mais ça n'est pas seulement une loi
technique même si nous aurons de longues
heures à passer ensemble sur de nombreux
articles qui sont pour certains d'entre
eux effectivement techniques cette loi
veut répondre à un sujet simple celui du
refus du renoncement notre pays ne peut
pas ne doit pas renoncer face à la crise
du logement c'est à nous c'est à vous
qu'il revient de lui donner les moyens
d'affronter la dureté de la période
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs je vous
remercie merci merci Madame la
Ministre la parole est à présent à notre
collègue Claude Dilain rapporteur de la
commission des affaires
économiques monsieur monsieur le
Président Madame la ministre monsieur le
Président de la Commission madamees et
Messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues je voudrais dire madame la
ministre en introduction que ce projet
de loi dont nous allons parler là
pendant de longues heures était attendu
il était attendu parce que d'abord vous
l'aviez vous en étiez engagé à le
présenter et je vous remercie d'avoir
tenu parole ce projet de loi est dense
et ample il est ample et dense par parce
qu'il recouvre une grande partie des
probl problématiques du Logement et de
l'Urbanisme et on vous avait fait ici
même le reproche de vouloir couper en
tranche pour ne pas dire saucissonner
parce que c'est un très mauvais mot les
problèmes de logement j'aimerais
aujourd'hui qu'on ne vous fasse pas le
reproche que cette loi est 150 articles
et qu'elle soit trop dense parce que
sinon il y aurait une contradiction elle
était attendue aussi parce que nous
allons faire en tous les cas en ce qui
concerne ma partie référence à des lois
anciennes 65 70 89 les dates parlent
d'elles-même et quelquesunes avaient
subi des modifications mais certaines
comme la loi n'avait absolument pas
bougé votre projet de loi est est
équilibré et je pense que c'est là une
chose importante sur lequelle il faudra
pas dévier les équilibré en ce qui
concerne les droits et devoirs des uns
et des autres enfin toujours en
introduction votre loi est déterminée
elle est déterminée parce que enfin
enfin vous allez permettre d'avoir des
outils
pour traiter les copropriétés dégradées
traiter le problème de
l'alubrité traiter le problème des
marchands de sommeil qui dans certains
territoires mine complètement la
société c'est une
loi merci monsieur le rapporteur c'est
une loi que nous
attendions
merci en ce qui concerne après cette
introduction en ce qui concerne la
commission des affaires économiques elle
a adopté le 9 octobre dernier le projet
de loi pour l'accès au logement et un
urbanisme rénové allure après avoir
sensiblement modifié enrichi au terme de
11h de réunion et 339 amendements ont
été ainsi
déposés le dépôt de ce projet de loi
ambitieux comme je l'ai dit constitue
aux yeux de la commission une nouvelle
illustration de la prior donné par le
gouvernement à la politique du
logement depuis mai 2012 de nombreuses
mesures importantes ont été prises dans
ce domaine je pense tout d'abord à
l'entrée en vigueur dès le 1er août 2012
d'un décret sur l'encadrement de
l'évolution des loyers dans les zones
tendues destiné à lutter contre la
spéculation et les hausses abusives de
loyer je pense au relèvement du Pla fond
du livra en octobre 2012 puis en octobre
2013 ceci afin de renforcer le
financement du logement
social je pense également à la loi du 18
janvier 2013 relative à la mobilisation
du foncier public qui permet la session
de terrain d'État et des établissements
publics avec une décote pouvant
atteindre 100 % pour assurer la
construction de logements sociaux cette
loi a également relevé les obligations
de construction de logements sociaux
dans les communes soumises à l'article
55 de la loi SRU et vous comme vous le
savez mon cher collègue d'aller j'y suis
particulièrement
sensible je pense aussi au niveau au
nouveau dispositifs fiscal en faveur de
l' de l'investissement locatif le Duflot
qui a été mis en place à l'occasion de
la loi de finance 2013 avec un plafond
de loyer fixé à 80 % du loyer du marché
en fonction des zones je pense encore à
à la lettre d'engagement du 12 novembre
2012 entre l'État et Action Logement
marqué par le renforcement de
l'intervention d'Action Logement en
faveur du logement social je pense aussi
au au au pacte d'objectifs et de moyens
conclus en juillet dernier entre l'État
et le mouvement Hlm comprenant notamment
l'engagement de l'État de réduire à 5 %
au 1er janvier 2014 le taux des le T de
TVA pour la construction et les travaux
de rénovation de logements sociaux mais
aussi la mise en place d'un dispositif
de mutualisation financière entre les
organismes je pense enfin la liste est
longue mais tant mieux je pense enfin à
la loi d'habilitation du 1er juillet
2013 qui a ouvert plusieurs chantiers
visant à réduire les délais de
procédurees associé au lancement de la
réalisation de chantier de construction
leord d'ornance relative au recours
abusif qui était tellement attendu
tellement demandé dans cet homicycle et
ailleurs prévu dans ce texte a
d'ailleurs été publié le 17 juillet
dernier le présent projet de loi
s'inscrit donc dans la continuité de ces
différentes initiatives prises depuis
mai 2012 et qui visent toutes à répondre
à la crise du logement j'en viens
maintenant au contenu du projet de loi
la commission des affaires économiques a
décidé au vu de l'ampleur des lois de
désigner deux rapporteurs sur ce texte
je me suis donc occupé du Titre 1 et 2
tandis que mon collègue Claude berribat
s'est chargé des titres 3 et
4 le titre premier vise à favoriser
favoriser l'accès de tous à un logement
digne et
abordable le premier volet porte sur la
réforme de la loi Malandin Mermaz
autrement dit la loi du 6 juillet
1989 tendant à améliorer les rapports
locatifs ce
volet vise
a moderniser le rapport entre bailleurs
et locataire tout en préservant ou en
améliorant l'équilibre de ces rapports
il comprend plusieurs mesures
importantes don certaines avaient été
voté d'ailleurs par le Sénat en 2011
dans le cadre de la loi Le Fèvre il
s'agit notamment de la création d'un
contrat de location type ou d'un modèle
type d'état des lieux qui constitue une
garantie tant pour le locataire que pour
le
bailleur le forcement des obligations du
locataire en matière d'assurance le
projet de loi permet au propriétaire de
souscrire une assurance pour compte du
locataire récupérable bien entendu
auprès de
celui-ci la réduction du délai de
préavis à un mois pour les locataires en
zone T tendu l'extension de
l'application de la plupart des
dispositions de la loi de 89 au logement
meublés qui jusqu'à présent sur la
logement meublé de résidence principal
jusqu'à présent y échappa la création
une véritable sanction en cas de non
restitution du dépôt de garantie par le
bailleur dans un délai légal de 2
mois la mesure phare de ce volet est
bien entendu l'encadrement de
l'évolution des loyers dans les zones
tendues sur la base des données
collectées par les observatoires locaux
des loyers qui seront créés le préfet
fixera un loyer médian de référence et
les loyers ne pourront pas être
supérieurs à plus de 20 % à ce loyer
médian
cette mesure est très attendue par nos
concitoyens je vous rappelle qu'au cours
des 20 dernières années les loyers ont
augmenté plus vite et même bien plus
vite que les revenus des locataires avec
un indice 100 en
19943 en
1993 les loyers sont passés à 137 en
2006 dans le même temps le revenis moyen
des locataires est passé de 100 à 117 on
voit certaines familles françaises et en
parti parulier parmi les plus pauvres
qui consacrent jusqu'à 48 % de leur
revenus pour leurs dépenses de logement
pour leur
loyer la commission des affaires
économiques n'est pas du tout convaincu
par la critique selon laquelle le texte
du projet de loi sera inflationniste
notamment pour les plus modestes la
modif les modifications introduites par
les députés permettent d'éviter tout
risque de ce type les loyers situés sous
le loyer médian minoré fixé à 70 % du
loyer médian rférence pourront être
évalués par le bailleur au
renouvellement du bail mais ils ne
pourront pas dépasser ce loyer
minoré sur le volet de la loi de
1989 la Commission a introduit dans le
texte des dispositions complémentaires
visant notamment à encadrer davantage
les pénalités en cas d'impayer de loyer
sans les supprimer à encadrer le
complément de loyer exceptionnel ou à
rétablir l'encadrement de l'évolution
des loyers au renouvellement dans les
zones non tendues qui avaient été
oubliées par l'Assemblée
nationale les députés ont également
introduit C article relatif à la
location meublée de courte durée alors
c'est une problématique certes qui est
essentielle dans les zones tendues et et
notamment à Paris où il y a 20000
logements qui sont transformés en en
locaux meublés temporaire alors qu'il y
a une demande de logement considérable
il convient donc de renforcer la
régulation de cette
activité le deème volet de ce titre
porte sur la garantie universelle de
loyer l'article 8 tel qu'adopté par les
députés se contentait d'énoncer le
principe de la Gul sans en préciser les
modalités et d'ailleurs les débats qui
se sont développés dans la presse ont
largement dépassé le cadre de cet
article la Commission a introduit dans
le texte à l'initiative gouvernement des
dispositions importantes visant à
préciser ce dispositif l'instauration de
laagul fait débat mais la commission des
affaires économiques est convaincue de
son intérêt notamment du fait de deux
éléments les dispositif antérieur car la
volonté d'une garantie de loyer est
ancienne et ma collègue marine Noel
linman pourra en
témoigner les dispositifs antérieurs
n'ont pas fonctionné
on compte à peine 250000 contrats de GRL
il est évident que le marché ne peut pas
gérer un système assurantiel de ce type
et que l'échec de la GRL car c'est un
échec tout le monde le reconnaît est dû
à l'absence de caractère universel et
probablement aussi au peu d'intérêt pas
dire à pétance des
assureurs certains estiment que le
dispositif est trop favorable au
locataire on a évoquer très largement
l'aléa morale je mets des guillemets
alléa moral mais tout le monde sait ce
que ça veut dire il n'en est rien et je
vous proposerai d'ailleurs au cours de
la
discussion un amendement qui permettra à
l'agence de à l'agence de la Gul de
recourir au trésors public pour
récupérer les les les impayés de loyer
je sais par expérience que le taux de
recouvrement par le Trésor public est
bien supérieur à celui existant
aujourd'hui en matière d'un payer de
loyer le trisème volet de ce titre porte
sur la réforme de la loi de 70
réglementant les conditions d'exercice
des activités relatives à certaines
opérations portant sur les immeubles et
les fonds de commerce c'est la loi auug
ces dispositif renforce la formation la
déontologie et le contrôle des
professions de l'immobilier et les
auditions m'ont confirmeré que nombre
d'entre elles attendaient ces
dispositifs le je parle des
professionnels comme par exemple la
création d'un Conseil national de la
transaction et de la gestion immobilière
chargé de représenter les professionnels
et qui sera consulté par les pouvoirs
publics ou les commissions régionales de
contrôle organes disciplinair chargé de
sanctionner les manquements aux règles
de de
déontologie le 4è
volet porte sur la prévention des
expulsions le projet de loi les
mécanismes existants afin de traiter les
impayés le plus en amont possible et de
coordonner les actions de prévention les
locataires seront informés très
précisément de leurs droits et les
différents acteurs huissier préfet
commission de coordination des actions
de prévention expulsion locative et
CAPEX fond de solidarité pour logement
FSL devront communiquer entre eux de
façon systématique pour apporter des
solutions précoces et
adaptées la la Commission a amélioré la
précision de ces dispositifs proposés
l'Assemblée nationale ayant qute à elle
principalement induit une une
possibilité d'élargissement de la trve
invernale en fonction du climat sur
décision du préfet mais je pense que
nous en reparlerons pendant le
débat le 5è volet vise à faciliter le
parcours de l'hébergement au logement il
donne une base législative en même temps
une reconnaissance au servicees intégrés
d'accueil et d'orientation
qui ne relevait jusqu'à présent que de
la circulaire il vise surtout à
rationaliser ce dispositif essentiel et
à renforcer le pilotage de l'État il
renforce également l'articulation entre
logement et hébergement ainsi que la
gouvernance des mécanismes au niveau
régional la compétence du comité
régional de l'habitat est étendue aux
politiques
d'hébergement les plans départementaux
consacrés aux personnes sans domicile et
les plans départementaux relatifs aux
personnes défavoris
sont fusionné je dirais enfin les règles
de fonctionnement du FSL sont précisées
en particulier pour favoriser non
seulement le maintien dans le logement
mais aussi des solutions de logement qui
nécessitent un apurement préalable des
dettes de certains
métage ce volet du projet de loi
comporte plusieurs sujets
sensibles tout d'abord il prévoit de
proposer des logements sociaux en bas et
glissant à des ménages relevant du droit
logement au logement
opposable c'est un débat mais la
Commission a choisi sur cette question
le pragmatisme entouré de
garantie ensuite le projet de loi vise à
simplifier les règles de de
domiciliation ce qui soulève la question
des limites de ce mécanisme et de la
logistique de la domiciliation car nos
centres communaux d'action sociale
pourrait voir leur charge de travail
augmenter enfin la Commission a proposé
à mon initiative une prolongation et
l'encadrement de l'expérimentation
permettant l'occupation des locaux
vacants par des résidents temporaires
qui correspond à des besoins spécifiques
bien
réels le dernier volet de ce titre porte
sur l'habitat participatif c'est un
sujet qui pour l'instant ne concerne que
plusieurs centaines de logements en
France contre plusieurs centaines de
milliers dans les pays d'Europe de du
nord de l'Europe c'est dire les marges
de progression de cette troisème voie du
logement ce qui justifie que le
législateur en perfectionne
l'encadrement
juridique le projet de loi crée deux
formes de société d'habitat participatif
d'une part les coopératives d'habitants
et des sociétés d'autopromotion et les
sociétés d'autopromotion ces dernièr ont
non seulement pour objet d'attribuer je
parle des sociétés d'autopromotion ont
non seulement pour objet d'attribuer à
leur associé personne physique la
jouissance d'un logement mais également
de leur en attribuer la propriété sur
cette question la Commission a notamment
précisé l'encadrement de la valorisation
des parts sociales jugeant raisonnable
de retenir l'idée d'une non spéculation
en choisissant qu base de référence
l'évolution des
loyers j'en viens maintenant au titre 2
du projet de loi qui porte sur la lutte
contre l'habitat indigne et les
copropriétés dégradées les articles 23
et 40 portte sur les copropriétés et
vous ne serez pas étonné que je sois à
titre personnel particulire attaché à
cette partie du texte ces dispositions
madame la ministre sont très attendues
et vous le savez vous avez pu vous en
rend compre sur le terrain et très
consensuelle elle s'inspire des
propositions formulées par le rapport de
notre ancien collègue et ami en ce qui
me concerne Dominique Bray et les
propositions que j'avais formulé en tant
que parlementaire en mission en avril
dernier les principales dispositions
sont les suivantes la création d'un
registre des syndicats de
copropriétaires ce qui devrait permettre
de sortir espèce de brouillard actuel il
n'y a en effet quasiment aucune donnée
relative au parc
descopropriétés le renforcement des
informations fournies dans les annonces
immobilières à la vente d'un lot de
cpropriété de façon à ce que les
acquéreurs sachent vraiment ce qu'ils
vont acheter ou ce qu'ils envisagent
d'acheter l'obligation du compte séparé
pour les syndicats de copropriétaires
pour l'ensemble des copropriété
l'interdiction pour un copropriétaire en
impayé de charge d'acquérir un autre lot
de la même copropriété il s'agit d'une
disposition essentielle que je réclamais
à cor et àit depuis longtemps et Madame
le Ministre à titre personnel je vous
remerci infiniment de l'avoir mis dans
votre projet de loi car c'est une arme
essentielle contre les marchands de
sommeil la réforme et le renforcement de
l'efficience des procédures prévues pour
respecter les copropriétés dégradées à
savoir la procédure du mand du
mandataire adoc la procédure
d'administration provisoire ou encore la
procédure de l'état de carence enfin et
je suis pas exhaustif la création des
opérations de requalification des
coupprpriés dégradé des opérations de
requalification des coupprpriés dégradés
d'intérêt national lorsque leur
complexité ou l'importance des
financements nécessaires et
malheureusement ça arrive ne permettent
pas qu'ell puisse être réalisé par des
collectivité
territoriale tout ça est nouveau et va
permettre un certain nombre de
collectivités territorial d'intervenir
efficacement sur des cpropriétés à
l'agonie je souhaite insister sur une
disposition importante introduit par
l'Assemblée nationale il s'agit du fond
de prévoyance cette disposition était
fortement proposé dans le rapport
braille et elle constitue une assurance
contre la dégradation des copropriétés
les députés ont proposé l'application
d'un tel fond au seul copropriété de
plus de 50 lots non couverte par la
garantie descinale ce qui ne
n'atteignait si je puis dire que 36000
coproprié était sur les plus de 700000
existantes la Commission a souhaité
abaisser ce seuil à 10 lot le seuil de
50 lot effectivement était trop
faible sur cette partie la Commission a
également adopté à mon initiative un
amendement
important visant à imposer au
copropriétaire qu'il soit bailleur ou
qu'il soit occupant de disposer d'une
assurance puisque ce n'était pas le cas
jusqu'à présent en effet plus de 50 %
des copropriétaires non occupants n'ont
pas d'assurance pour les risques dont
ils doivent répondre en tant que
copropriétaire cette situation peut
mettre en difficulté certaines
comppropriétés dont l'assurance doit se
substituer à l'assurance des du
copropriétaire
concerné l'autre volet de ce titre porte
sur les outils de lutte contre l'habitat
indigne il s'agit là encore d'un sujet
essentiel sur lequel nous devons nous
mobiliser la persistance d'un habitat
indigne rentabilisé sans scrup par des
marchands de sommeil est une réalité
très préoccupante dans les zones tendues
et de plus en plus préoccupante où
l'offre de logement est cruellement
insuffisante afin de combattre ce
phénomène l'article 41 propose des
mesures d'unification des polices
spéciales en matière d'habitat au
bénéfice de l'EPCI ceci n'épuise pas le
sujet de l'extrême complexité des
procédures entre elles tant concernant
l'insalubrité que le péril ou encore la
sécurité des équipements communs dans
les immeubles collectifs d'habitation
la Commission a sécurisé à mon
initiative ce transfert tout en
préservant bien sûr la liberté de choix
des maires je le dis on Nura pas de
débat là-dessus s'agissant de la lutte
contre les marchands de sommeil les
articles 42 et 43 bis C instore des
peines complémentaires à la condamnation
pénale interdisant l'achat d'un bien
immobilier à usage d'habitation pendant
5 ans ou confisquant l'usufruit des
biens ayant servi à commettre
l'infraction
l'article 46 ontant contraindre les
marchands de sommeil à réaliser des
travaux pour faire cesser laadesence
autorisant les caisses d'allocation
familiale à ne pas verser les
allocations logement le locataire ne
versant que le loyer résiduel
l'Assemblée nationale a également
introduit les articles 46 sexè et a et
46 sepè et et 46 OCS qui permettent
l'instauration d'un zonage dans lequel
est soumis à autorisation préalable du
maire ou du président de PCI des travaux
entraînant la division d'un logement
existant en plusieurs locaux
d'habitation ainsi que la mise en
location d'un logement ou encore un
régime de déclaration de mise en
location la commission des affaires
économiques a supprimé à mon initiative
l'autorisation préalable de mise en
location et nous en reparlerons car tout
en partageant l'objectif poursuivi le
dispositif proposé soulève trop de
difficultés tant J que pratique et il
pourrait affaiblir la protection des
locataires nous reviendrons bien sûr sur
cette question
difficile j'en ai donc fini mes chers
collègues monsieur le Président avec la
présentation des de titres dont j'ai la
charge dans j'ai la charge comme je
l'indiquais ces deux titres sont très
riches et comportent des dispositions
très variées avec toujours le souci de
préserver l'équilibre dont je parlais
tout à l'heure beaucoup d'amendements
ont été déposés et je souhaite que le
débat parlementaire enrichisse
ce projet de loi madame la ministre en
maintenant un juste équilibre je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à Claude Berry Deb
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
économiques monsieur le Président Madame
la ministre mes chers collègues la
commission des affaires économiques m'a
désigné pour être le rapporteur des
titres 3 et 4 du projet de loi je ne
reviendrai pas sur les principales
dispositions de cette partie du texte
car madame la ministre en a fait déjà
une présentation très claire mon rôle
est plutôt ici de rappeler et
d'expliquer le travail réalisé en
Commission concernant le titre 3 qui
vise à améliorer la lisibilité et
l'efficacité des politiques publiques du
logement la Commission a peu modifié la
version du texte issu des travaux de nos
collègues députés nous avons estimé que
le nouveau dispositif de gestion partagé
de la demande de logement social dans le
bon sens toutefois nous avons choisi de
confier la gestion du système national
d'enregistrement des demandes de
logement social non pas à l'Agence
nationale pour l'information sur le
logement comme prévu initialement mais
en groupement d'intérêt public associant
l'État les bailleurs et les rés ataire
il s'agit de disposer d'un véritable
instrument dédié et professionnalisé
pour une tâche aussi délicate nous avons
aussi proposé que les communes soient
associées en amont dès la phase de
préparation du plan partenariat de
gestion de la demande de logement social
et que les bailleurs soient également
partie prenantes de l'élaboration du
plan car seule la mobilisation de tous
permettra d'améliorer le des demandes à
l'initiative de notre collègue Marie
Noël linemman dont je salue le travail
sur ce texte nous avons adopté toute une
série d'amendements visant à répondre à
des problèmes pratiques concrets ainsi
nous avons ouvert la possibilité
d'expérimenter en zone détendue la
dématérialisation des réunions des
commissions d'attribution afin de
répondre plus vite à la demande nous
avons aussi supprimé le plafonnement par
rapport à la surface du supplément de
loyer de solidarité plafonnement qui ne
fait que favoriser le maintien dans le
logement social des plus fortunés nous
avons également permis le prolongation
des effets du bail locatif après la fin
d'un bail à construction ou bail
anhitotique afin que les locataires ne
se retrouvent pas du jour au lendemain
occupant sans titre de leur logement
enfin à l'initiative conjointe de
mesdame Blandin l'État enem nous avons
cherché à neutraliser les effets de la
transformation du statut de la sinorpa
bailleur social du Nord Pas De calé issu
de l'histoire minière de cette région
transformation des l'idé cidé dans la
loi de janvier 2013 et je pense que vous
vous en rappelez nous avions eu des
débats dans cet
hémicycle le nouveau dispositif unifié
de contrôle des acteurs du logement
social sous l'égide de l'Agence
nationale de contrôle du logement social
a été pour l'essentiel validé par les
commissions des affaires économiques du
Sénat une telle réforme était attendue
elle a été peu retouchée nous avons
simplement veillé à bien séparer la
mission de contrôle de la mission
d'évaluation de l'ancol et prévu une
procédure de publicité et de publication
des remarques des organismes contrôlés
ou évalués comme cela existe pour les
rapports de la Cour des comptes
le projet de loi prévoyait d'étendre et
de sécuriser au regard du droit européen
l'émission des bailleurs sociaux nous
sommes allés le plus loin possible dans
ce sens en effet le régime fiscal et les
aides publiques ne peuvent bénéficier au
bailleurs sociaux que égard au service
d'intérêt économique général qu'il
rendent nous devons pas donner à la
Commission européenne d'arguments pour
remettre en cause ce régime spécial du
logement social au moment où les
professionnels de l'immobilier le
contestent devant la Commission
européenne pour autant nous avons estimé
pouvoir permettre expressément aux
organismes HLM d'exercer des missions de
syndique solidairire ou encore de
prendre des initiatives communes pour
pour mieux remplir leur mission nous
avons été amenés à débattre de deux
choix politique important contenu dans
le titre 3 et le projet de loi le
premier concerne les sociétés d'économie
mixte de construction et de gestion de
logement social le projet de loi les
soumets à agrément comme les organismes
HLM ce coin est contesté par les C et de
nombreux élus or les SEM réclament dans
le même temps les mêmes droits que les
organismes HLM nous les leur accordons
en leur permettant par exemple de se
voir attribuer le bonis de liquidation
d'un office public de l'habitat d'ous et
de bénéficier des droits
d'enregistrement réduit lorsqu'elle
rachète des logements sociaux à d'autres
bailleurs mais on ne veut pas à la fois
aligner les droits des SEM sur ceux des
organismes HLM et supprimer le leur
agrément dans un souci de simplification
je vous proposerai toutefois durant nos
débats en séance un amendement qui tout
en maintenant le principe de l'agrément
prévoira que la signature une convention
d'utilité sociale va vaudra agrément
pour les seèes le deuxième sujet sur
lequel nous avons déboutu est celui du
rattachement des offices publics de
l'habitat aux intercommunalités il ne
semble plus possible de faire reposer le
logement social sur de petits opérateurs
municipaux l'intercommunalité et
l'échelon pertinent à matière de mise en
œuvre de la politique de logement même
s'il faut veiller à maintenir un lien
inroit entre les les maires notons en
demeurant que les maires gardent leurs
représentants dans les commissions
d'attribution de logements sociaux
enfin nous avons pris quelques
initiatives comme par exemple celle de
faciliter l'usufrit social montage
original qui permet aux bailleurs
sociaux de ne pas avoir à supporter
l'intégralité de la charge d'une
opération autorisant à construire plus
avec moins de capitaux nous avons
également jeté les bases juridiques
nécessaire pour faire fonctionner le
dispositif de mutualisation entre
organismes HLM sur lequel le mouvement
HLM et l'État se sont accordés dans le
pack d'objectifs et de moyens signés le
8 juillet 2013 bref si nous n'avons pas
bouleversé les grands équilibres du tit
3 j'estime que nous avons dans un esprit
pragmatique perfectionner les
dispositifs proposés et apporter
quelques compléments nécessaires pour
améliorer la
de l'efficacité de la politique du
logement j'en viens maintenant au titre
4 du projet de loi consacré à la réforme
des documents de planification
urbanistique et à celle des outils
d'aménagement
opérationnel le sujet qui a donné lieu
aux discussions les plus passionnées est
évidemment celui du transfert
automatique de la compétence plu aux
communautés d'agglomération et de
communes le PLU intercommunal présent de
vrais avantages et beaucoup
d'intercommunalités l'ont compris et mis
en
application depuis quelques années déjà
dans la France d'aujourd'hui c'est le
niveau d'organisation de l'espace le
plus pertinent et le plus efficace parce
qu'il permet de rassembler la capacité
d'ingénierie indispensable à la
réalisation de pu de qualité et parce
que même dans les communes rurales la
vie des habitants est désormais
organisée à une une échelle qui dépasse
largement les frontières de la commune
j'ajoute qu'à mon sens le PLU
intercommunal ne dépouille pas les
communes de leurs compétences en matière
d'urbanisme au contraire pour les 13000
communes qui ont été citées tout à
l'heure surtout des communes rurales qui
ne sont pas couvertes par aucun document
et sont soumises de plein droit au
règlement national d'urbanisme le
transfert de compétences et donc pour
elle la reconquête au niveau
intercommunal d'une compétence perdue de
facto au niveau communal mais en tant
que rapporteur de la commission des
affaires économiques j'ai résolument
pris en compte ses interrogations voir
cette opposition au pui tout mon travail
a en effet reposé sur un constat initial
le texte sorti de l'Assemblée nationale
n'était pas votable en l'état au Sénat
et ce même si les députés avaient
apporté au texte initiale du
gouvernement des aménagements
pertinents je suis content d'avoir votre
approbation mes chers
collègue le problème à résoudre n'était
pas simple conserver le principe d'un
trans transfert automatique de la
compétence plu sans renoncer à celui de
la libre détermination communale la
solution que j'ai proposé à la
Commission tient en trois
points le F de la compétence PLU est
repoussé 3 ans après la publication de
la loi ce qui laisse à toutes les
intercommunalités communauté de communes
et communauté d'agglomération et aux
équipes municipales le temps de se
mettre en place mais surtout il est
institué un mécanisme de minorité de
blocage le transfert de la compétence
aura
lieu sauf si un/art des communes
représentant 10 % de la population s'y
oppose cette disposition mes chers
collègues redonne un pouvoir de décision
très fort aux communes et même je dirais
plus fort qu'avant 3è point de ma
proposition une clause de revoyure si
une minorité suffisante de commune s'est
opposé aux transfert le conseil
communautaire est tenu de délibérer de
nouveau sur la question lors de son
renouvellement les communes membres se
prononcent à alors selon le même
mécanisme de minorité de blocage cette
proposition que vous avez soutenu madame
la ministre et je vous en remercie a été
largement adoptée par la commission des
affaires économiques elle a permis de de
raller de nombreux sénateurs et
sénatristes qui étaient opposés à
l'origine au transfert du PLU aux
intercommunalités
elle figure désormais dans le texte et
si vous nous voulons qu'elle y reste il
nous faudra tenir compte de la réalité
institutionnelle cette réalité en effet
c'est en effet que l'Assemblée nationale
a voté et largement voté le transfert
automatique de la compétence peldu et
qu'elle aura son dernier mot dans la
navette en cas de désaccord entre les
deux chambres dans la perspective de la
discussion des amendements j'attire donc
votre attention sur un point entre les
aménagements R à l'Assemblée nationale
et les avancées obtenues par la
commission des affaires économiques nous
avons à mon sens atteint un point
d'équilibre tous les amendements qui
tendent à donner encore un peu plus de
pouvoirs au communes sont intéressants
lorsqu'on les considère isolément mais
mis bout à bout ajouté aux modifications
déjà intervenu il dessine en réalité un
dispositif potentiellement moins
favorable à l'intercommunalité que le
droit actuel à trop demande prenons
garde mes chers collègues de ne pas
perdre ce qui a été
acquis notre pouvoir et notre
responsabilité en tant que sénateur est
donc d'infléchir la direction du texte
pas de défendre un projet alternatif
nous pourrions dire non en supprimant
l'article 63 et en rester au droit
actuel mais dans ce cas la réforme du pu
se fera sans le Sénat
et le texte qui sortira du Parlement
sera sans doute plus éloigné de ce que
les uns et les autres nous aurions
souhaité madame la minist madame la
ministre j'ai un appelle à l'ensemble du
Sénat et l'ensemble du Sénat avec moi à
votre soutien pour défendre les avancées
obtenues par le Sénat dans la suite de
la naverte j'espère que vous m'avez bien
écouté madame la ministre
je n'en dis pas plus sur cette question
pour en venir à d'autres thèmes
importants en ce qui concerne les
établissements public foncier la
commission a entendu garantir la
cohérence des périmètres entre EPF
d'État et EPF locaux en soumettant toute
superposition à l'accord des
collectivités concernées toutefois nous
aurons l'occasion de faire évoluer cette
disposition pendant l'examin des
articles examinant une proposition
d'accord pour la création d'epf d'État
àquis à la majorité des 2 tiers de
l'assemblée générale des EPF locaux
concerné concerné par la
superposition la Commission s'est
également employée à sécuriser les
innovations introduite par les députés
en première lecture sur l'exercice du
droit de préemption en replaçant
clairement les session de part de s dans
le champ d'application du Pr du plan de
préemption du droit de de premption
pardon enfin concernant la question
d'Urban de l'urbanisme commercial nous
savons que l'attente du Sénat est très
forte dans ce domaine or la réforme a
été introduite dans le projet de loi par
petitbout par voie d'amendement sans
visibilité d'ensemble par ailleurs ce
qui a été introduit n'était pas
satisfaisant trop poche du droit
existant avec par exemple le maintien
d'une double autorisation CDAC permis de
constru
manquant d'ambition et qui de sur croit
poser des problèmes juridiques lourds
bref les conditions dans lesquelles le
Sénat aborderé cette réforme était à mes
yeux mauvaise j'ai donc décidé en accord
avec la ministre du Commerce l'artisan
et du Tourisme de supprimer les
dispositions introduites par l'Assemblée
nationale sur l'urbanisme commercial ce
qui nous permettra au cours de la
navette de réintroduire le sujet de
l'aborder de matière plus cohérente et
plus sereine et surtout de pouvoir
l'introduire très fortement dans le
projet de loi qui nous parviendra et qui
sera issue de la proposition faite par
la ministre du Commerce de l'Artisanat
et du Tourisme voilà les principales
modifications apportées au texte au
stade de l'examen en commission quelques
mots maintenant sur un autre thème
important que les débats en séance
publique permettront sans doute de faire
avancer celui des constructions en zon R
de très nombreux amendements portent un
effet sur cette question dans ce domaine
deux impératifs doivent être conciliés
le premier constitue l'un des axes
principaux du projet de loi à savoir
inciter à une consommation plus économe
de l'espace passant par une
densification des zones déjà urbanisées
et une protection accrue des zones
agricole naturelle et forestière le
second tout aussi important et de pas
mettre S sous cloche les territoires
ruraux il faut donc trouver des
solutions pragmatiques pour faire
coexister des utilisations parfois
antagoniste de l'espace d'un côté
développer ou préserver le potentiel
agricole de l'autre maintenir ou attirer
la population et le tourisme le tout en
protégeant les espaces naturels et les
paysages les équilibres ne sont pas
forcément simples à trouver nous
quittons l'hémicycle du Sénat mais nous
reviendrons plus largement sur l'examen
du projet de loi logement dans notre
édition de 19h mais tout de suite c'est
l'émission politique de la rédaction de
Public Sénat preuve par 3 qui reçoit ce
soir Pierre Laurent le secrétaire
national du Parti communiste et sénateur
de Paris à tout à l'heure
19h